I have to ask you about the
one of the interesting developments with
large language models
is that they're able to generate code uh
recently really well
I guess to a degree that maybe a
I don't know if you understand but I
have I struggle to understand because it
it forces me to ask questions about the
nature of programming of the nature of
thought
because the uh language models are able
to predict the kind of code I was about
to write so well yep that it makes me
wonder like how unique my brain is and
where the valuable ideas actually come
from like how much do I contribute in
terms of uh Ingenuity Innovation to code
I write or design and that kind of stuff
um when you stand on the shoulders of
giants are you really doing anything and
what L alums are helping you do is they
help you stand on the shoulders of
generality program there's mistakes
they're interesting that you learn from
but I just it would love to get your
opinion first high level yeah of what
you think about this impact of large
language models when they do program
synthesis when they generate code yeah
also
um
I don't know where it all goes yeah
um I'm an optimist and I'm a human
Optimist right I think that
um things I've seen are that a lot of
the llms are really good at crushing
leak code projects and they can reverse
the link list like crazy
um well it turns out there's a lot of
instances of that on the internet and
it's a pretty stock thing and so if you
want to see
standard questions answered LMS can
memorize all the answers and that can be
amazing and also they do generalize out
from that and so there's good work on
that but um but I think that if in my
experience building things building
something like you talk about Mojo where
you talk about these things where you
talk about building an applied solution
to a problem it's also about working
with people
it's about understanding the problem
what is the product that you want to
build what are the use case what are the
customers you can't just go survey all
the customers because they'll tell you
that they want a faster horse maybe they
need a car right and so a lot of it
comes into
um you know I don't feel like we have to
compete with L alums I think they'll
help automate a ton of the mechanical
stuff out of the way and just like you
know I think we all try to scale through
delegation and things like this
delegating wrote things to an llm I
think is an extremely valuable and the
approach that will help us all scale and
be more productive but I think it's a
it's a fascinating companion but I'd say
I don't think that means that we're
going to be done with coding
but there's power in it as a companion
and yeah so from there I could I would
love to zoom in onto Mojo a little bit
do you think uh do you think about that
do you think about llms generating Mojo
code
uh and helping sort of like when you
design new programming language it
almost seems like man it would be nice
to sort of
um
almost as a way to learn how I'm
supposed to use this thing
for them to be trained on some of the
most good so I do lead an AI company so
maybe there will be a Mojo llm at some
point uh but if your question is like
how do we make a language to be suitable
for llms yeah I think that the
um
I think the cool thing about LMS is you
don't have to right and so if you look
at what is English or any of these other
terrible languages that we as humans
deal with on a continuous basis they're
never designed for machines and yet
they're the intermediate representation
they're The Exchange format that we
humans use to get stuff done right and
so these programming languages they're
an intermediate representation between
the human and the computer or the human
and the compiler roughly right and so I
think the LMS will have no problem
learning whatever keyword we pick maybe
the Phi Emoji is gonna oh maybe that's
gonna break it it doesn't tokenize no
the reverse of that it will actually
enable it because one of the issues I
could see with being a super set of
python is there would be confusion about
the gray area
so it'll be mixing stuff uh
but well I'm a human Optimist I'm also
an llm optimist I think that we'll solve
that problem but
but you look at that and you say okay
well
reducing the rote thing right turns out
compilers are very particular and they
really want things they really want the
indentation to be right they really want
the colon to be there on your else or
else it'll complain right I mean
compilers can do better at this but um
lens can totally help solve that problem
and so I'm very happy about the new uh
predictive coding and copilot type
features and things like this because I
think it'll all just make us more
productive it's still messy and fuzzy
and uncertain unpredictable so but is
there a future you see given how big of
a leap gpt4 was where you start to see
something like llms inside a compiler
uh I mean you could do that yeah
absolutely I mean I think that would be
interesting it's not wise well well I
mean it would be very expensive so
compilers run fast and they're very
efficient and LMS are currently very
expensive there's on device llms and
there's other things going on and so
maybe there's an answer there
um I think that one of the things that I
haven't seen enough of is that
so llms to me are amazing when you tap
into the creative potential of the
hallucinations right and so if you're
building doing creative brainstorming or
creative writing or things like that the
hallucinations work in your favor
um
if your writing code that has to be
correct because you're going to ship it
in production then maybe that's not
actually a feature
and so I think that there there has been
research and there has been work on
building algebraic reasoning systems and
kind of like figuring out more things
that feel like proofs and so I think
that there could be interesting work in
terms of building more reliable scale
systems and that could be interesting
but if you chase that rabbit hole down
the question then becomes how do you
express your intent of the machine
and so maybe you want LM to provide the
spec but you have a different kind of
net that then actually implements the
code right so it's a used documentation
and and inspiration versus the actual
implementation yeah potentially